[Musique]
h
autour du monde des peuples ont bâti
leur vie et leur maison sur
l'eau le bateau joue un rôle essentiel
dans leur
existence au Bénin sur le lac
nosa est un homme indispensable à la vie
de son village à bord de de son taxi
pyog il transporte ses
concitoyens au Pérou au cœur du lac
titiaka léo est un
aara il vit sur une île ou plutôt un
confetti flottant constitué de roseau
tout comme ses
[Musique]
bateaux une journée dans la vie de deux
hommes qui vivent sur l'eau et naviguent
à la manière de leur
précurseurs
[Musique]
le lac Nokoué se situe au Bénin au nord
de Cotonou la capitale du pays cette
région est la plus grande zones humide
du pays elle s'étend sur plus de 900 km
Carr
au début du 18e siècle pour échapper au
chasseurs d'esclav à la solde des
Portugais des fugitifs trouent refuge
dans des marage et
inospitali ilond le village de Gier
aujourd'hui près de 40000 personnes sur
pil dans des maisons de bois et de
bambou on les appelle les les hommes de
l'au est un taxi pog qui a le sens des
affaires il possède plusieurs
embarcations les plus grandes font la
navette entre ganvier et
Cotonou on ne devient pas pyoguier du
jour au lendemain c'est un métier qui
s'apprend mon grand-père conduisait déjà
une pyogue c'est lui qui a appris à mon
père comment naviguer puis mon père me
l'a enseigné à son
tour maintenant c'est moi qui transmet
ce savoir-faire à mes enfants qui plus
tard vont le transmettre
aussi c'est comme ça
ici deux de ses fils sont déjà dans le
métier ce sont eux qui assurent la
traversée entre ganvier et la capitale
un voyage d'unh et dem sur des barques
bondées qui peuvent accueillir jusqu'à
passagers ce matin un trou dans la coque
du bateau préoccupe
UNSA une réparation de fortune avec un
morceau de tô fort à l'affaire
la pirogue pourra prendre le
départ mais plus préoccupant le
brouillard est tombé sur le village
comme souvent durant la saison
sèche donne quelques conseils de
prudence à ses fils
allez doucement quand vous démarrez et
regardez toujours la voix si vous
avancez prudemment vous partirez sain et
sauf et vous reviendrez sa et
[Musique]
sauf avant de partir des passagers
s'achètent de quoi manger au marché
flottant où des lbes des dizaines de
vendeuses s'activent sur leur flottill
de pirogue
[Musique]
cet ép brouillard qui recouvre ganvier
est causé par l'écart de température
entre les eaux froides du lac et le
souffle chaud de l'armatan un vent qui
provient du
[Musique]
Sahara
la pirogue c'est ma vie c'est ma
réalité c'est primordial pour tout le
monde ici d'avoir accès à une
embarcation tu veux te déplacer tu as
besoin d'une
pirogueyz tous ces gens qui passent
autour de nous à bord de leur
Pirog pour nous c'est comme avoir une
voiture ou une moto sur la terre ferme
c'est notre mode de
transport avec ces milliers de cases
surpilo gvier est la plus important cité
la custre d'Afrique de l'Ouest on la
surnomme la Venise du
Bénin n'avons pas l'eau potable
ici pour en avoir il faut apporter no
bassines jusqu'au puit et acheter l'eau
à la pompe qu'on rapporte ensite à la
maison pour boire et
cuisiner il n'y a pas d'électricité
alors on doit utiliser des lampions et
des
[Musique]
lanternesa est rentré chez lui pour
partager le premier repas de la journée
avec ses plus jeunes fils iris l'une de
ses trois épouses a préparé de l'bas un
plat fait de pâte de manioc et de sauce
tomate au poisson
fumé j'aime manger avec mes enfants le
matin les enfants doivent manger avant
d'aller à
l'école doiv être rassasié pour être
attentif en
classe
après avoir mangé les enfants vont
partir à l'école en pirogue la pirogue
est essentielle pour nous même pour les
plus jeunes ils feront aussi monter des
camarades sur la
[Musique]
pirogue du village vont à l'école les
autres travaillent pour subvenir au
besoins de leur
famille et dans les salles de classe il
n'y a qu'une seule fille pour 10
[Musique]
garçons à l'autre bout du monde un autre
peuple vit sur l'eau
le lac titiaka est le plus haut lac
navigable du monde il s'étend à 3800 m
d'altitude entre la Bolivie et le
Pérou côté péruvien le lac est parsemé
d'une centaine d'îles artificiell les
îles flottantes nommé ouros nom du
peuple indigène qui les occupait
autrefois bien qu'il existe plusieurs
théories sur le sujet tous s'entendent
pour dire que c'est pour échapper aux
vers le 13e siècle que les ourau sont
trouvés refuge sur l'eau puis s sont
établis les ourau sont aujourd'hui
disparu remplacé par les
[Musique]
aaras le jour se lève sur le lac titiaka
on a boêtre en é la température ne
dépasse pas 0
[Musique]
degr Léo habite l' wi balo qui en
espagnol signifie marin pour
toujours
ce matin il part relever ses filets de
pêche avec ses
parents le lac tiaka est très important
pour
nous c'est lui qui nous
nourrit je le trouve aussi très
beau quand le soleil apparaî on peut
admirer le bleu de
l'eau lorsqu'il se couche on sent le
vent qui se
lève et on voit les vagues qui se
forment
c'est
[Musique]
magnifique aujourd'hui la pêche est
plutôt
maigre le poisson pris dans le filet
s'appelle Kachi un petit poisson du lac
qui se fait rare détruite introduite ici
par des biologistes américains au siècle
dernier sont devenus de redoutables
prédateurs
après la pêche on ira sur la péninsule
pour faire du
troc on pourra échanger nos poissons
contre des pommes de terre de l'orge du
maïs et plein d'autres
choses
[Musique]
les poissons sont ensuite nettoyés et
rassemblés pour le troc car chez les
aaras comme chez les ouros autrefois la
nourriture ne s'achète pas elle
s'échange léo et sa famille embarquent
pour la péninsule de lukina terreferme
la plus proche qui se trouve à plus
d'une demi-heure de leur île c'est là
que s'effectue le troc avec les
agriculteurs de la
[Musique]
côte
pour signaler leur présence il dressent
une perche ornée d'une couverture en
guise de
drapeau
c'estta la mère de Léo qui dirige les
opérations les premières clientes
arrivent ce sont les femmes qui gèrent
le troc et qui échangent le poisson
ici toujours les femmes quand on ne peut
pas les échanger alors on va les
vendre les hommes sont des pêcheurs et
les femmes sont des commerçantes c'est
comme
ça c'est 5 kaki contre cette quantité de
pommes de terre parfois je donne un
poisson en
plus plusieurs de mes pommes de terre
ont été mangé par les
veres il y en a beaucoup qui sont gâté
elles sont toutes petites car je dois
les récolter avant qu'il les
[Musique]
dévore Léo et les siens vivent et
travail de manière communautaire comme
le faisaient les
[Musique]
ouros les gains et les marchandises sont
partagé équitablement entre les
habitants de lîle tous membres de la
même
[Musique]
famille les tâches sont également
réalisé à
plusieurs j'aime beaucoup construire ces
embarcations
traditionnelles j'en fabrique pour
transmettre mon savoirfaire
enfs nous fabriquons ces bateaux
principalement pour la collecte des œufs
et la chasse aux
oiseaux c'est aussi une manière
d'honorer le mode de vie de nos
ancêtres cette plante utilisée par Léo
et son frère silver pour fabriquer leur
bateau est un roseau commun au lac
titiaka appelé totora
che our l' de construire les
embarcations de tot
traditionn de génération en
générationend leour grâ les
PE estun des él les plus de notre
culture depuis
toujours les murs des mais pour
constituer l'île flottante pour faire de
l'artisanat mon chapeau par exemple est
lui aussi fait
det c'est quelque chose d'important et
pas seulement pour construire des
[Musique]
bateaux pour mettre la chance de son
côté Léo doit inaugurer son nouveau
[Musique]
bateau comme le veut la tradition c'est
un habitant de la Côte qui préside la
[Musique]
cérémonie cette fois c'estin un marin de
la ville de qui accomplit le
rituel à tousux qui sont présents ici
aujourd'hui je vous remercie de m'avoir
choisi comme Parin je bris la bouteille
pour inaugurer le
bateau
bonne chance merci
[Musique]
8h du matin ganvier dans le Sud du
Bénin UNSA va chercher son premier
client il s'agit de Joseph taxi
piroguier comme lui dont la pirogue est
en
réparation ma PIR sera prête dans 3
semaines ce n'est pas si long tu as
raison je vais me débrouiller mais d'ici
à qu'elle soit réparée j'aurais
peut-être besoin
d'accord taxi pirogier c'est notre
métier et on doit arriver à se
[Musique]
débrouiller c'est qu'on nous appris à
nous les nous sommes de bons
PIR pour pas continuer à faire ce
travail très longtemps on se fait vieux
déjà mais quand tu es un homme tu dois
trouver un
travail tu dois faire au moins quelque
chose pour nourrir ta famille
et pouvoir t'en
[Musique]
occuper
josephrois un bateau
deèler t V de blanc il ch
dansul la
divinité qui protè adepes de la maladie
de la
sorcellerie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leou c'est notre culture notre
tradition ça a toujours été comme ça et
ça le restera on pourra jamais
abandonner le vaudou toi tu Esan un
prêtre vaudou je suisou et c'est ma
culture comment je pourrais renier ça
oui c'est vrai jamais je ne me
convertirai à une autre religion c'est
je ne peux pas renoncer à ce que je
suis le Bénin est le persceau du vaudou
plus qu'une religion le vaudou est
depuis des siècles une culture une
philosophie une manière de vivre la
majorité des habitants de ganvier le
pratiquent UNSA se rend chaque jour à
laabogillo la cabane de son grand-père
pour y pratiquer un rituel
[Musique]
chaque élément du rituel a sa fonction
propre la noix de cola pour invoquer les
dieux Leal pour procurer un parfum de
paix le sodat pour apporter l'abondance
joies et enfin l'alcool pour éloigner
les
[Musique]
ennemis
j'ai essayé le
christianisme je suis allé dans une
église chrétienne mais au fil du temps
je me suis rendu compte que les hommes
ne s'occupent pas vraiment de
Dieu c'est Dieu le Père qui a créé les
églis et c'est le même Dieu qui a permis
auou de naître dans l'église où je suis
allé la richesse et l'argent prenent le
pas sur les croyances et les pratiques
religieuses c'est là que j'ai réalisé
que leou avait vraiment sa place
et
[Musique]
qu' à
présent rendre visite à le menuisier qui
fabrique sa nouvelle
pirogue il veut voir l'avancement des
[Musique]
travaux bonne
arrivée bonjour Comment ça va bien bien
les PES son
con un bois qui provient du
[Musique]
Nigéria la pirogue la dimension j'avais
demandé
non pas tout à
fait on devait recevoir des morceaux de
bois de 4
m mais on a plutôt reçu des morceaux de
3 m 3 m
dem mais regarde touche OK je regarde
ça c'est du bon
bois vous les clients il faut pas que
vousartiz d'ici avec l'idée que je
fabrique de mauvais
pyog alors vérifie bien assure-toi que
c'est du bon bois et que j'ai bien fait
mon
travail ça me semble très bien c'est du
solide vous pouvez la retourner pour que
je regarde de l'autre
côté
attention avec la
modernisation c'est possible qu'un jour
les gens n'achètent que des barques
commerciales et que mon métier
disparaisse j'ai appris la menuiserie
alors je peux construire des pirogues
mais je peux aussi construire des
charpentes de maison si la faque
à disparîre j'aurais toujours la
possibilité de construire des maisons
[Musique]
surpil pour sa future pyogue tient à
peindre lui-même sa nouvelle
Paget il faut la rendre attrayante pour
attirer le regard des clients la couleur
est aussi un marquage qui permet de
l'identifier en cas de
vol
j'embell ma paguet en la
peignant ça représente l'amour que j'ai
pour mon travail et les clients aiment
ça c'est pareil pour ma tenue c'est une
question d'amour propre et de préférence
aussi quand je suis sur l'eau je
m'habille proprement je m'habille bien
et j'affiche mes
vêtements porte le chapeau traditionnel
le Gobi seul les hommes m ont le droit
de le
porter vous voyez mon chapeau il est
fait pour être posé tout droit sur la
tête alors quand je le penche comme ça
ça veut dire sois humble et tu en
[Musique]
profiteras la journée est bien avancée
sur le lac titiaka à bord de son Nau
nouve bateau Léo se faufile dans le
dédal des
roseaux il est à la recherche de de
canard des Andes des oiseaux endémiques
de la
[Musique]
région ici la terre ne nous permet pas
de cultiver du quinoa ou des pommes de
terre notre activité principale c'est la
pêche ensuite on chasse les oiseaux et
on récolte leurs œufs
[Musique]
les 16 habitants de l'île Winnie balcero
compos la famille de Léo ses parents ses
qu frères leurs épouses et leurs enfants
vivent côte à
[Musique]
côte mais
famille chaque fois qu'un garçon se
marie il doit construire sa propre
maison pour y vivre avec son épouse
c'est sa
responsabilité ch possède son chef qui
en devient le
président par exemple sur notre c'est
mon père qui tient ce
r c'est un ancien et il a beaucoup plus
de savoir que
nous il peut nous apprendre comment bien
vivre sur l'île et comment prendre
soin
il a toujours plein
d'idées et nous apprenons beaucoup avec
lui l'île de roseau est totalement
artificielle
elle mesure environ 15 m de diamètre et
3 m
d'épaisseur le niveau du lac varie avec
les saisons quand l'eau devient trop
profonde l'Î risque
[Musique]
aujourd'hui léo et sa famille doivent la
déplacer vers une zone du lac moins
sensible il y a 11 ou 12 encres qui
maintiennent l'île en
place sans les encres le vent et les
vagues pourrait nous emporter au
[Musique]
loin pour bouger l'île qui est bien aré
on doit d'abord enever les
les encres sont très
lourdes ensuite nous utilisons de cordes
qui font 70 m de longueur pour
l'attacher bouger on a besoin de nos
bateaux à
moteur regarde la perche l'île
[Musique]
avance
les hutes de totora sont à la fois très
petites et hautement
inflammables c'est toujours à
l'extérieur par tous les temps que Léo
et les siens prennent leur repas au menu
poisson pomme de terre fève et UF de
canard
c'est un déjeuner typique c'est mon plat
favori de la journée et c'est le plus
copieux parce qu'on travaille
dur ma femme s'appelle
Martina ma filleé
[Musique]
s'appelle le petit dernier mon fils il
s'appelle
ran il aura bientôt 2
ans et voici ma niè de 5 ans
is j'ai rencontré ma femme en jouant au
foot lors d'une fête annuelle organisée
par la
communauté quand j'étais plus jeune je
voulais rencontrer une femme qui habita
sur
parce que je crois que les gens ont une
meilleure éducation
là-bas ici quand tu es jeune le seul
avenir qui s'offre à toi c'est de
devenir
pêcheur et en même temps ici la vie est
simple
calme alors je me suis dit que je serais
plus heureux avec une femme qui vient de
chez
[Musique]
moi
au Bénin UNSA poursuit tranquillement sa
journée de taxi
pyogier il aime bien son métier mais sa
vraie passion est
ailleurs je suis un musicien à la base
un musicien et un chanteur je fais de la
musique traditionnelle mais je me suis
vite rendu compte qu'ici ça ne suffit
pas pour faire vivre sa famille
pour nourrir et entretenir tout le monde
j'ai dû me trouver un autre
gagneepain c'est comme ça que j'ai pensé
au taxi
pyog tout le monde en a besoin et ça me
permet de subvenir à mes besoins
personnels et à ceux de ma famille en
attendant que les opportunités en tant
qu'artiste se
présentent la musique ça ne suffit pas
pour gagner sa
[Musique]
vie
dans cette cité la custre où tous les
déplacements sont difficiles le pyoguier
se fait parfois
[Musique]
ambulancier à 25 ans enceinte de 6 mois
victoire attend son 5e enfant
tu as rendez-vous avec le
médecin oui je voudrais bien le
rencontrer la sagefemme sera là
aujourd'hui je ne sais
pas tu as un souci avec le bébé tu m'is
prévenu que tu voulais aller à la
clinique je serais venu te chercher plus
tôt je me
[Musique]
dépêcher
à ganvier il n'y a qu'un seul
dispensaire et qu'une seule sage femme
chantalounou
elle pratique en moyenne un accouchement
par jour elle suit les femmes enceintes
celles qui viennent d'accoucher et les
nouveau né ses journées sont bien rempli
il y a de bébés en fait il ont moins
d'une semaine il y a une maman qui s PL
de fièvre que l'enfant en train de
chauffer j'ai pris la température c'est
à 37 de bon j'ai d d'ouvrir un peu les
fenêtres que ça ça va passer la plupart
des maladies soignées au Centre de santé
de ganvier sont lié à
l'eau il y a un peu plus de moustique on
a surtout les affections comme le
paludisme le choléra aussi les maladies
liées à l'eau les salmonéos bon c'est le
quotidien bonsoir parfois il y a des
complications on est obligé d'envoyer au
niveau supérieur mais là il faut une
bque équipée qu'on n' pas donc on envoie
les maris chercher les BES ceux qui ont
des bques motorisé les autres c'est des
piroges bon donc on a besoin d'une bque
motorisée bque ambulance quoi c'est
notre idéal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
s'accorde une pause au marché
flottant un bout de pain un thé glacé
c'est suffisant pour reprendre des
forces
[Musique]
retour au Pérou Antonio le père de Léo
emmène toute la famille se recueillir à
la petite chapelle catholique
la chapelle des miracles de bronze situé
sur une île
voisine un jour le grand-père de ma
femme qui était parti pêcher au milieu
du lac s'est retrouvé coincé toute la
nuit sous la pluie et la grêle avec des
vents très
forts c'était très
dangereux il a survécu
maisemaintin a trouvé une croix de
bronze sur son bateau de
totora il a pu rentrer chez lui et
depuis nous louons le saint qui a
accompli ce
miracle on lui demande d'obtenir du
travail et de pouvoir faire de bonnes
affaires on demande aussi à la D
de ne pas nous envoyer trop de vent car
il détruit nos filets et la pêche n'est
pas
bonne quand il n'y a pas de vent on peut
prendre un peu de poisson qu'on va
troquer ensuite contre des pommes de
terre et des Fèvres comme nous l'avons
fait
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
de retour sur l'île Antonio montre
comment assembler les roseau pour
construire une
toiture est le gardien de la culture
des pour que le tradition manière de
vivre perd à travers
les savoaire à s
en le to pour déterminer à quel moment
il faudra construire un autre pas plus
d'un
on utilise d'abord du bois pour faire la
structure de la
maison ensuite onse le tot pour
fabriquer les murs et le
toit on ne peut pas construire une
maison tout
seul on doit travailler tous
ensemble c'est aussi plus agréable de
travailler de cette
façon je suis pas très
rapide ça va comme ça tu peux le rouler
à
présent notre vie est difficile mais
nous sommes nés ici nous avons
l'habitude de ce mode de vie et nous
arrivons à supporter le
froid le fait de vivre ici plutôt
qu'ailleurs
ça nous permet aussi de maintenir nos
tradition ici la vie est belle mais
plutôt
fraîche pour le futurt pour
enants une éducation de
l'argent la possibilité d'aller en ville
pour poursuivre des études et avoir une
profession
[Musique]
au Bénin UNSA a prévu de se rendre dans
un port situé à 8 km de
ganvier mais avant la traverser il doit
faire le
plein
[Musique]
pas de station service officielle ici on
passe directement chez des particuliers
qui traverse la frontière et achète au
Nigéria pays voisin et producteur de
pétrole le carburant à bas prix le
trafic d'essence est aujourd'hui la
seule source de revenu de la moitié des
habitants du
pays pour faire la route jusav
une P commciale une barque elle peut
transporter beaucoup plus de
gens le voyage vers le port de Calavi
est très lucratif près de 1
€ à ganvier pas d'orair fixe la grande
pirogue ne partira que quand elle sera
pleine
[Musique]
ce trajet entre ganvier et calav est
beaucoup plus rentable pour moi quand je
trouve assez de passagers pour faire
cette traversée j'ai une bonne
[Musique]
journée si tu maîtrises bien ton moteur
et si tu contrôles bien la conduite de
ta barque il n'y a pas de grand danger
sur cette voie
mais il faut vraiment y être
[Musique]
habitué mtin est une cliente régulière
d' tous les jours elle fait la traversée
vers Calavi pour vendre ses poissons au
[Musique]
marché
Calavi est la deuxème ville la plus
peuplée du Bénin après Cotonou dans le
marché toujours très fréquenté on trouve
de
toutier il n'y a pas de marché au
poissons comme celui de
Calavi les poissons on peut les pêcher g
mais il faut venir jusquici pour trouver
les clients qui vont les
acheter ici c'est vrai
marché aur besoin d'un grand marché à
ganv nous
aussi ja b
[Musique]
b
en fin de journée une fois de retour à
ganvier reprend la Pirog pour aller
pêcher avec son fils Cadé
[Musique]
mchac quand je vais à la pêche avec mes
enfants ça représente beaucoup plus que
de simplement passer du temps avec
eux quand tu vas à la pêche tu as besoin
de quelqu'un pour t'aider tu as besoin
d'un coup de main je préfère que ce soit
mes propres enfants qui
m'aident qu'il y ait du poisson ou pas
ça n'a pas d'importance au moins mon
enfant aura cette connaissance et il
saura que c'est une activité qu'on
pratique à
ganvier pasagayer à bord de la pirogue
toute la journée c'est comme faire du
sport c'est très
exigeant c'est fatiguant de diriger
l'embarcation d'aller de venir comme ça
tout le temps sans
arrêt mais il y a également une fierté
lorsqu'on se déplace sur l'eau je n'ai
pas besoin de me retrouver sur la terre
ferme à bord d'une moto ou d'une
voiture ma fierté c'est ma
[Musique]
pirogue sans Pirog tu ne peux rien faire
et tu ne peux aller nulle
part c'est notre véhicule et c'est la
réalité des habitants de notre village
c'est la pirogue qui fait
ganvier quand la nuit tombe sur la cité
laustre le taxi pirogier le papa pêcheur
devient chanteur sa
passion la nuit et forcément au fil de
l'eau
[Musique]
sur le lac
titicaka les familles isolé sur ces îles
minuscules ont besoin d'entraide et de
solidarité pour
survivre
plusieurs fois par an tous les aaras des
îles ouros se rassemblent pour exécuter
des travaux
communautaire aujourd'hui on récolte des
roseau pour les besoins de l'école
[Musique]
primaire si on récolte pas le
totora et si on coue pas il va se
détériorer de couleur et
mourir là où il y aura desaras il y aura
du
Totor notre communauté le coupe et le
récolte alors le totora peut continuer
de
pousser
la partie blanche du totora se mange
pour nous c'est un peu comme manger de
la
[Musique]
banane pour t jusquà l'école lo et
Silver doivent l'attacher et le
remorquer
[Musique]
lentement vue du ciel leur embarcation
semble parer d'une immense queue de
roseau onoyant sur les EAU du
lac
l'école primaire des aaras se trouve à 2
km de lîle ou
[Musique]
villeéo tous les ans au mois de mars
juste avant la rentrée
scolaire tous les pères des enfants qui
fréquentent l'école doivent récolter du
totora et l'orter dans la cours de
l'école c'est important que les enfants
aient une a de jeu propre fait de
nouveaux
Totor quand les roseau sont vieux et
humides ce n'est pas bon pour les
enfants ils peuvent se
blesser alors tous les pères se
retrouvent ici et on travaille tous
ensemble c'est un mode de vie
communautaire une tradition qui nous
vient de nos
ancêtres nos ancêtres ont toujours
travaillé en communauté et en
s'entraidant encore plus qu'aujourd'hui
quand on travaille tous ensemble comme
ça ça me fait plaisir parce que ça me
permet de revoir des amis et de faire de
nouvelles connaissances on travaille
tous dans la joie et ça nous permet de
nous connaître les uns les
autres
[Musique]
après le travail on mange tous
ensemble et on dispute un match de
football sur le terrain pour que les
roseau soient bien
[Musique]
compact
je ne crois pas que notre communauté
puisse
disparaître nous qui vivons sur le lac
nous n'avons pas les diplômes pour vivre
en ville et quitter nos
îles nous ne sommes pas très
éduqués mais nous avons des
connaissances ancestrales notre pêche et
notre manière de travailler le
totora je vis ici et je ne peux pas
imaginer abandonner cet endroit pour
habiter
ailleurs on sera ici encore
longtemps
quand le match se
terminera chaque famille retournera sur
son île et reprendra les gestes du
quotidien dans cet univers d'eau et de
roseau unique au
[Musique]
monde au Bénin comme au Pérou des hommes
et des femmes ont trouvé refuge sur
l'eau ils se sont adaptés à cet univers
aquatique hors du
monde une vie singulière rythmée par le
vent les flots et les
[Musique]
bateaux